[Music]
let's talk about frozen this is a huge
monster hit congratulations because you
guys have an Oscar nomination for the
film and you have a doll and all of your
character I don't know yeah which is I
think it's always a sign that you're
going places when you have your own doll
it's pretty it's it's interesting you
know try me yeah yeah it does say try me
I don't know what that's all about but
the it's funny because we found this out
today this is not the first time that
you've had a doll or a toy
representation of yourself you haven't
it's not with Veronica Mars they made a
little a little bus us a little bus of
you that they sold yeah when you're
Veronica Mars and we got ahold of it and
it is the we I mean I'm just it is not
it is one of the weirdest looking
depictions of anybody this is supposed
to be you get in tight get in tight on I
mean first of all there's the bell but
look at the face you look like Jared
Leto
it's corpse makeup first of all yeah
I've got a choker ons you know and look
at the boot those are not my boobs you
guys that's we're trying to break free
of your arm I think I must've been
posing like this or something and then
but and then the huge thick belt yeah
this is about the ugliest representation
I could ever draw of myself but you know
the saddest part about this cuz I hate
when this is busted out they scanned me
for this so unfortunately this is
exactly what I look like responsibility
that is you and I love that whole
attitude you got there like I gave those
as Christmas presents to my house of
lies cast to the first season yeah Josh
and Ben they all have them in their
office I mean it's it's the worst you
can't you can't get hurt I don't think
she's she's just staring you down
calling her the worst worst it's gonna
keep you know what its gonna stay here
for all time next two eyes power
you tweeted a picture recently this you
said this was you from the future
I guess many people have tweeted a
future yeah this is uh I guess this is a
face of a vase you take a picture and I
didn't actually even do this one a
friend of mine right when that face
first came out took a picture of me and
then sent it back fat-faced and yeah I
think inevitably that's what I'll look
like someday yeah we did one week one of
me I think we've got around here
somewhere again show it it says I don't
know why it's I guess this endlessly
amusing that's what happens to all Irish
people our heads expand
as we get older we have a clip here from
House of Lies anything you can tell us
about yeah this clip I think is well
interestingly enough Ryan Hansen who's
my best foot in the world was on this
episode and he kind of plays my pseudo
boyfriend and Don Cheadle is getting
kind of jealous that he's come to visit
me sticking with this clip from House of
Lies hey sorry I left my yep there it is
what up hey what's up bro what's going
down
hey you doing man he came straight from
softball last night said I'm gonna
capture you don't say yeah alright you
know what I should get going duty calls
so alright hey say awesome please don't
leave them hanging found it out thank
you
alright oh I think you might be the one
genius right because every girl you've
ever fiha reticle physicist so he's a
catcher now what position does he play
on the South box oh no you do not get to
have the genie with a strap-on fantasy
sorry Marty you had your chance you blew
it
[Applause]